hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast performance assessment of
RNA sequencing and expression arrays for
transcriptome analysis in cancer
research presented by peter nazareth
research scientists bioinformatics and
modeling group proteome and Genome
Research Unit Department of Ecology
Luxembourg Institute of Health I'm
Alexis corrosive labyrinth and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
this educational web seminar is brought
to you by lab birds and sponsored by
thermo Fisher Scientific for more
information on our sponsor please visit
their month ensure calm don't let's get
started before you begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into that ask a
question box and click on the send
button well answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window click
on the arrows at the top right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I'd like to now introduce
our speaker dr. Peter Nazareth dr. Peter
now Ralph is a research scientist in the
proteome and Genome Research Unit of the
department of oncology at Luxembourg
Institute of Health in an invited
assistant professor at Luxembourg
University dr. Nazareth produced over 30
publications devoted to data analysis
and oncology its primary expertise in
biostatistics machine learning and
genomics his recent work focuses on
characterizing transcriptional
variations in peri tumor tissue
environment of pancreatic cancer
as little tumors originated from lung
colon skin and brain it's current
research leverages deconvolution of
transcriptomic signals from
heterogeneous tumors to improve cancer
classification dr. Nasra you may now
begin your presentation think your exes
for this nice introduction hello
everyone so today we will speak a little
bit about the performance assessment of
RNA sequencing an expression raised for
the scotoma analysis in cancer research
but not only about this in fact I have
two parts in this presentation we will
start comparing in a second microwave
performance so we shall see how similar
the results are what are the specific
features of both platforms when you
study coding and non-coding genes for
example and what kind of strange things
we observed looking at the Eternity
splicing by these both techniques and
for the second part I will briefly
introduce you a method which is used in
transcriptomics which can which can be
used just transcriptomics for the
convolution of complex mixed signals
from different cell types and try to
convinced you that it's a great method
to which can help us understanding more
about cancer so let's begin them and the
first part of the talk is based on the
paper which we published just last year
in BMC genomics so if you have more
questions about it you can get through
to learn through this and have a look
next let's go so why we are we're
interested in comparing different
platforms in literature usually people
claim that Erin ASIC is outperforming
array techniques and well for some
situation that's true result in question
but we were a bit
because in majority of cases people tend
to take quite old micro arrays like for
example of matrix you want three three
arrays which are three prime ivt which
have only prop sets in it's let's say
three prime of each transcript and
compared to quite new technique which is
RNA sequencing so we check we would like
to see what would happen if we take the
modern arrays like HD version two by the
way now there is a successor of it
called clarion 30 arrays so what will
happen if we take this modern arrays and
which have probes through all the
transcriptome including the junctions
between different exons and compare it
to Aaron a sec in our view such kind of
comparison would be more fair so we are
interested in how the results are
similar in terms of expression what is
the correlation between protein coding
genes between other bio types between
exons what differences can be observed
with these platforms and ultimately to
find some suggestions which platfrom
should one use if he's doing research if
he's doing some kind of standard
analysis and so on what we've done we
took nine patients with lung squamous
cell carcinoma the data were presented
to us by the French institution in turn
serve invested of five of us and we took
from these patients from each one two
samples while I was taking from the
tumor core another one from adjacent
normal tissue so total we had like 18
samples those samples were processed in
a standardized way and analyzed by a
symmetric HTE version two arrays we used
hundred mammogram of the immature
they're always luminous I said 2012 used
from 500 to one mic from 100 nanograms
to one microgram I've mentioned that in
this situation for sequencing we use a
poly selection this might be important
to see the results to understand the
results and we can only target with this
technique then those genes which have
poly a tail this is something for us to
remember in the sequencing we aimed at
library size of 2 million base pairs so
what we got after alignment
after mapping we got like from 120 to
280 million base pairs three million
reads each one composed of 77 base pairs
buried in general we saw that normal
tissue which is represented here by
green color is a little bit more
homogeneous in number of map reads for
cancer we have more we have more
variability the orange color here just
to describe in brief what kind of method
we use what kind of strategy we used I
prepare the next slide so for arrays we
went through a kind of standardized
pipeline we took the cell files we
analyze it with party genomic suite
which can be for example replaced by
transcriptome analysis console if you
don't have that says to the software so
the normalization was performed and
propped summarization within the tool we
use a remain for normalization with GC
contact correction
afterwards we continue with props that
expression and these probe sets were in
fact REM mapped on the genome in order
to be able to characterize as many genes
found in RNA sack as possible for Aaron
a sack we used start was with fastq
files we perform alignment with stock
hat and then the bass files were
analyzed as a with HD sack for gene
expression always feature count from our
background actor it's the method the
function would say from the earth sub
reads in order to count exons
unfortunately HD sack was not able to
count exons there are some technical
issues with this so next let's see what
we get in terms of characterization of
the genes we took two groups of genes
for consideration the protein coding
genes those which are standard well
known and also the non-coding RNAs long
coding RNA where we combine together
several subtypes which you can see on
the left
so those subtypes which are here
represented by the green boxes are
combined all together and form the group
of long non-coding rnas just a map
remember we have poly excitation that's
why we have only the other end seeds
which still have the poly a tail the
coverage after a mapping of HD was
amazingly good so we got like over
almost all protein coding genes were
found back the vast majority of fallen
C's were found back as well
and this worked both on the level of
genes and on the level of exons below we
have the Venn diagrams for the level of
exon cover overlap
between the two platforms next if you
would like to compare the jeans one
compare the data one of the way would be
to use something like dementia rate
reduction method the principle component
analysis for example and if you take the
data as they are of course you will see
all the differences between different
scale of the data in there in a second
in microarrays that's what's represented
here we have received two big clusters
fortunately this kind of bias is
consistent and can be removed for
example by simply subtracting mean and
dividing my standard deviation so by
something scaling the data afterwards
looked much better they form two
clusters normal and tumors and we saw
quite many similarities in Boston PCA
and also by the heat map on the right
between the same samples studied by both
techniques for non-coding RNA for
lincrnas we saw approximately the same
picture just with his increased noise
basically but still the same two
clusters were found next we check for
the correlation between the genes coding
and non-coding in terms of log signal
the correlation was 0.76 we used here
Spearman correlation just to avoid the
questions about the scales so it's based
on ranks and for the full change it was
like 0.74 so quite high correlation was
observed between the signals and for
changes for coding mRNAs however Foyle
and CRNAs the correlation was much less
exciting let's say 0.3 only we start
investigate what was the reason for this
and camera lock is the point that it
seems to be linked to G legs so on the
left you have here the scatter plot for
one patient measured
by both techniques by HDA and their own
attack in terms of intensity of the
signal in terms of full change between
normal and humors examples what you can
see is the most correlated genes are
those are colored here by red right and
for those genes the lengths was higher
than 6000 nucleotide for those genes
with length less than 2,000 nucleotide
represented by blue here the correlation
was quite ugly I must say and when we
have a look at lncRNA stem coding Rene's
what we can see is that the majority of
these zones is have length below 2,000
nucleotides which means they are in the
in the group of lowly correlated there
is quite low correlation if you see
carefully you might see some red dots
here as well which as well show high
correlation but unfortunately the rest
not next as we see that there is local
quite low correlation for the genes with
low expression we were not happy with
the results comparing microarray and
Ernest egg for non-coding genes we start
to find out what causing this problem so
lengths can be one explanation
we checked also the part of variability
which can be explained by those factors
which we can control an experiment like
patient to patient variability or tumor
normal variability so the effect of
patient to effect of state and we use
the method called a principal variance
component analysis PVC a which showed us
the part of total variability which can
be explained by those two factors and
those part of our ability which cannot
be explained by anything so those are
residuals we see here that
the majority of variability come from
tumor-normal difference and that's good
and also that the H there on a stack
which is in red here show higher
unexplained portion of variability
compared to HD for a linker in a foil
and CRNAs
the behavior was very similar except
that we can see much more unexplained
variability in earnest AK so it leads us
to idea that perhaps there is something
not so nice in Kiruna sack we start
investigating more about this
we checked what is the behavior of gene
variability with its expression on this
slide and we saw that in normal tissue
the same as the tumor tissue in both
cases our Nasik show high variability
especially for lowly expressed genes
this is represented by the red line
which is always above so high
variability above the blue line is HTA
based on this we can tell that the
majority of variability in our nest egg
come from those genes with low signal
small number of reads as a it can be
linked to length or to the expression
level next we go for the standard
analysis which is differential
expression analysis we used a gr method
for an s AK and Lima for HDA what we
found is that in most of the cases with
we try different threshold right and
with majority of the threshold except if
you take extremely extremely low FDR but
for reasonable of the are levels HDA
outperform rnaseq in terms of number of
significant digits of course the number
of significant genes doesn't mean that
the math is better so we needed to
compare with something and we
per the data with TCGA and USC data set
from TCGA quite many samples I included
there we found that the confirmation
level is approximately the same so HD
produce higher number of genes with the
confirmation Retton level about the
jacket index for example was 0.2 and our
nest egg produced less but with the same
jacket index so number of confirmed
features was also decreased but the
proportion stayed the same
similar results were obtained with
non-coding RNA however we were not able
to confirm almost any of our calling our
name is CJ because it's not oriented on
non-coding genes but some of them were
compared were found back next question
which we asked was linked to what is the
detection limits of each technique we
all know that rnaseq have a higher
dynamic range it's obvious people speak
about this but what you proposed in the
paper is not to compare the data as they
are but rather to concentrate on the
genes which are differentially expressed
which we just identified on the previous
slide so why not - look at those genes
which are differentially expressed
consistent between different biological
replicates and see what can we tell
about dynamic range and that's the
result here on this slide the dynamic
range is indeed higher for an attack
without an equation it's it's time for
an attack in terms of log two and five
in terms of entire and five for HT
however if you look at the lower limit
of absolute fall change which
can be detected by the matter you will
see that for HD it's much lower so an
attack produced you much higher
variability in your data but can detect
a reasonably high level of full change
whereas HTA produced quite small
variability but also detect a tiny
differences in local change so that's in
fact an interesting finding I think
telling that despite the dynamic range
is high for aeronite sec but there are
some kind of also cost to pay for this
high dynamic range so we checked as well
whether we can find the genes which can
be used as a predictive markers between
cancer normal of course it's not very
wise to find try to find predictive
markers in the group of only nine
patients you need a much bigger cohort
but we tried just to see that the
tendency and what we saw is that in
coding and non-coding genes you see more
genes with area under the curve above
0.95 in HTA for example here you have
distribution of all the genes
characterized by there an area under the
curve AUC which goes from 0.5 for
completely random situation to 1 for
ideal classifier so you can see that HD
in in this kind of test outperformed our
nesic with number of the genes with
predictive power both coding and
non-coding we try to confirm the results
with TCGA and we found basically a very
similar number of confirmation number of
confirmed genes so conformation level
was quite stable
next we checked what kind of interesting
things we can find if we feed now the
significant genes - enrichment analysis
tool if like if we try to find some
biological process which are enriched
sorry which are enriched I have some
issue with my computer that's strange I
think it's all now I hope so
whether we can find the same biological
functions looking at the significant
genes in RNA sack and in HD in fact
their strongest signals and the most
important biological processes which we
investigated and which I enriched with
the significant genes they are the same
it's the cell cycle for example Cillian
organization and the movement which is
very specific to one tissue cell
division and so on however there were
some biological processes which are
detected only in specific platform for
example in Erin a sec we saw more a
biological processes linked to
[Music]
extracellular matrix organization for
example so something related to outside
of the of the cell and for HTA we saw
more specific things linked to DNA so
working inside nucleus this was
interesting finding for us so we go
deeper and check what happened with the
cellular components which are more
specific and indeed with cellular
components we find the extracellular
matrix within a sec
the internal part and something linked
to DNA a nucleus nucleoplasm with HD
specifically of despite the fact that
majority of solar components were common
between two platforms so we try to find
out what can give us this bias and what
we've done we took the genes which are
correct which are involved in cellular
components specifically identified with
aramaic and specifically identified with
HTA so those red and blue line here
arrows show that we take the genes from
these components and check the
expression level of those genes in our
Nasik experiment and in HTA and Ernest
AK is on the Left HT is on the right so
exactly the same genes were checked in
two platforms whether we can see
something similar in fact we saw similar
feature we saw that the genes which are
unique for Aaron s tech based components
they are are always high expressed than
those which are unique for HD so which
they a little bit lower expressed we
checked also whether we can find the
same with biological processes but no it
was specific to cellular components
despite the fact that biological
processes as well so it showed some bias
but we were not able to find those
specific genes there so solar components
play a role and we also check whether we
can explain this bias by the lengths
variability of the genes which are
working in nuclear plasma extracellular
matrix no we were not able to find to
confirm next we try to correct for the
bias which is which can be linked to the
lengths affect the shorter genes are
hard to characterize with a renessa
because just they are shorter so we use
this specific tool called geo sec
to correct for the effect of the lengths
we got no improvement or almost no
improvement let's say we still were able
to take the same bias so it cannot be
explained by the lengths but rather by
the abundance of the RNA it seems that
those genes involved in the production
of protein for the cellular matrix are
more abundant than those which are
working afterwards in the nucleus and
that's it with the gene expression
analysis next we go for analysis of
splicing events and here we use the two
levels of information first of all we
use the expression of the exons and
second we use the expression of the
junction between the exons both
technique can give us this information
we started first trying to use HT sack
for exons it doesn't work just because
there are many overlapping excellent in
genome so they are not going to work
properly
don't try even I would say HT SEC is for
genes it work greatly for genes but not
for exons for exams we used feature
count from our sub read package and the
correlation was again quite high if we
start comparing the level of the signal
between two platforms the correlation of
the signal was 0.6 0.7 a little bit less
than genes but still reasonable however
as soon as we went for the analysis of
differentially used exons or splicing
events we found very strange picture we
saw that the overlap is almost random
between two platform well it's not
exactly random it's modern random we
check the statistics but it's still very
very low so like three point four
thousand common and
in 223 significant exons found in
Aramaic and 27,000 significant exon
found than HDA we checked also the
junction for junction we got much lower
number of significant in the error
message still of their lap was very poor
afterwards we try to combine X for each
platform X own and the junction together
in order to have something confirmed
from both levels we got a three point
three thousand Aran a SAG found exons
found Byron a sec and like 12,000 found
by HD a but still the overlap was very
low what can be the reason of this we
looked in this and find out that it
seems to be linked always two things
first of all is the location in the
transcriptome if you look on this or
curves here does represent probability
density of a splicing event to be
detected in HT and their nest egg in
depending on the location in the
transcript so from 5 prime to 3 prime
taking take out all the data so you see
clearly we have a pic with Aran a sack
at 3 prime those exons more often found
to be significant in a sack and also we
found that the longer axons the red line
here longer axons in earnest sack have
tendency to be more often found fine
found like differentially spliced so
there are like two reasons we checked
the data quite many genes one by one the
general tendency was like this is just
to example two genes in the on top you
have HT and Ernest egg for one gene in
the direct trend and below in the
reverse strand so what you can see is
that with our own a set with always have
increase of the signal intensity to
three prime and in both cases and quite
stable results for HT a it of course
could be linked to the fact that the
last section in genes tend to be longer
which you can find out between whatever
database however even if we corrected
for this bias we were still able to see
some discrepancies so it doesn't correct
the results at all so we still so quite
low overlap and on the lower picture for
example you still see that in the
terminating in zone 3 prime you have
much higher or a little bit higher still
number of significant exons than in
other parts so with this I would like to
conclude the first part of the talk in
our study
it seems that HT a really shown more
reliable results than earn a sec with
200 million reads just to remind you
that the study was performed around I
think over five years ago now or around
five years ago so maybe now the
situation has changed but so far what we
see we can confirm this result with
other studies we still see the same
problem there who is the variability
second point is that gene length
sensitivity makes her neck
technique for non-coding RNA and meaning
that as soon as you would like to
characterize short RNAs short
transcripts you should have much higher
coverage or you have to specifically
select those short transcripts by
something otherwise all your reads will
be coming from the longer more expressed
genes still Aramaic is a very nice
discovery tool so it's impossible to
study new transcript new regions which
are transcribed unpredictably without
this tool formation of chimerical in a
chimeric genes it's also impossible so
this is this should be of course noted
and the point which I would like to
bring to you be careful when you do as a
form study with whatever platform at
least with our experience there are some
issues and overlap between different
tools is quite low so be careful and try
to validate the results with other tools
with other methods so that's it for the
first part and now we should go for the
second part let's please give me one
second in the second part we are going
to speak about the intimated continued
parent component analysis in the
transcriptomics this is a project which
I'm interested in a lot and in which I
am working for the moment and to start
with let's begin with this strange slide
this is a visualization of the cocktail
party problem imagine all these people
standing together with music playing
having drinks and speaking and we are
particularly interested in what James is
telling so how do we how can we solve it
it's not an easy task as you can see
because you will get the sound from all
different sources and in fact this is
exactly the situation what we see when
we try to characterize a tumour tissue
by taking a bulk example a biopsy in
this biopsy you are going to have quite
many cells from various origin it can be
in this situation you can see you have
an Italian cells the normal cells in the
stroma the fibroblasts immune cells and
the cancer cells in which we are
interested and what you're going to get
is a mixture of all this transcriptome
in your sample of course you can make
the sample to purify the sample to have
like from 80 to 90 percent of cancer
cells but still the signal of immune
cells for example Eugen is not exact
about so it's almost always there and
your transcriptome will be still mixed
because you can have several subtypes of
cancer cells fortunately for the first
picture the solution was there is there
and was there for quite many decades I
think and the method is called
independent component analysis what you
should do in this situation you should
get as many linear combination of these
mix of signal as you can and you should
run them the method which is very
similar to PCA just with different
criteria which will separate
you their original signal into
statistically independent components
statistically independent signals and
then you can recognize what one person
was telling so how is the math work in
just a few words you should take the
samples from quite many patients as many
as possible and this is represented and
of course you can sequence it or do
microarrays visit so as a result you get
the quite quite large matrix of original
data with many samples and like 20,000
genes the method perform Attucks
decomposition so it's transformed this
into a matrix product of two matrices
the first one we can call for example
meta genes in space of genes and number
of components and the second one is how
each component is represented in each
sample so the first one show how each
gene is involved in each component and
the second one is how components are
involved in samples the genes are
statistically independent you can see
that there is no pattern at all in this
meta gene and only few genes usually
have an effect on each component and
those genes can be analyzed with
standard methods like with enrichment
analysis and you can link them then to
biological processes you can lean
components independent components to
specific biological processes the weight
of each component within the cohort of
patient can be linked to some clinical
observation for example subtype of
cancer or survival the patient's if you
would like to know more about this gene
I recommend the two papers below which
you can have a look to get more
information about the metal itself and
about its application so
just a few hints about what the method
can do and what it cannot do the
positive things about the method is that
it can find statistically independent
signals in the expression profiles based
on these independent components you will
be able to find the most important gene
within each components and thus you can
link it
we enrichment analogous to biological
processes you the method can tell you
what is the weight of each component in
the sample and so linking by this you
can link it to clinical data the
clinical observation the method does not
mean in fact to be run any additional
knowledge so we don't need to know the
profile of subtypes of cells like
subtypes the profile of leukocytes of
stromal opposite from ourselves of
cancer cells in order to make the
deconvolution you can use the data as
they are just one requirement that you
need a lot of data the answer is quite
robust
if you repeat your analysis you will get
the same results or almost the same
results except that no one tells you
whether the first component is going to
be first in the next analysis maybe the
first component will appear at the third
component or the tenth component but
otherwise if the component is found
there most often the days is the quite
robust component there is of course some
some contrast and some drawbacks of the
method there is no ranking of the
components not like in PC you can tell
that the first component is more
important than the second one the
results are still not deterministic so
there is some random noise some
randomness some components are always
found like in 99% cases but there are
some components which sometimes found
sometimes not not found they are not so
strong maybe they can be neglected in
the analysis or removed from the
analysis
daran tation of signal is arbitrary so
if component number one in first
analysis was linked positively to immune
signal than in the second analysis of
the same data you can find this is
component number three now called and
it's a negative part of its component so
we should take into account the specific
double orientation and the method is not
perhaps the best one if you look for
precise estimation of cell fractions you
will find the correlation vessel
fraction I'm pretty sure at least we
found it
quite often but maybe it will not you
give you a quantitative results at least
we were not able to get exactly
quantitative result qualitative yes
perfectly so we use this method we have
an idea of using this method for patient
classification how could we use it we
can take the large cohort of data like
for example coming from TCGA take new
patients we put them together run I see
on this big data set then using some
machine learning it can be random forest
for example which work for example for
the moment for us the best with random
forest you can train it on the TCGA data
and try to to predict the classes for
the new samples for the new patients in
addition to just classification you will
also get the knowledge about the biology
happening underneath you will be able to
link each component to biological signal
so what we've done we developed a
parallel ica which run in a consensus
way so there are many runs multiple runs
excluding each sample in the data set
which provide quite robust estimation of
both matrices the matrix of the meta
genes and matrix of them
[Music]
weights and just vision to show you some
kind of results we found I would like to
present you few slides if I have time we
started working with this project on
skin pyjamas melanoma
from TCG so we took like all the samples
available there at five samples from our
own and try to see what it can tell us
so in addition to telling what kind of
classes we expect for the new samples we
also checked what how good is the
accuracy of the method if you use the
one out cross validation on the training
set and the accuracy was quite
reasonable the gender was represent was
always found correctly so there's no
question about the gender the type of
the tumor is it metastatic of primary
was predicted like 479 percent of cases
and the subgroup of the tumor the the
cluster of the tumor was predicted with
90% accuracy which is quite reasonable I
think the nice thing about ICA is that
it not only fit for not only capture the
biological signals from different cells
of population but also can correct for
the bias in technique with different
platforms for example our data were
jumping out from the distribution of the
training data as you can see it here on
the Left PC picture however as soon as
you perform I see the data were quite
nice incorporated in the distribution
there were some components which capture
the differences between two platforms
and they keep the difference between
making the data available for further
analysis another nice feature about the
matter that you can perform independent
component analysis on several level of
data like mRNA at micro RNA and protein
and
combine them together into one cluster
of different components which are
targeting exactly the same process for
example we were able to find the immune
component at several level at mRNA at
micro RNA and the protein level and they
all were linked to survival of the
patients so we it means that combining
the information the weight matrices from
all these components together you can
build a kind of score which will
characterize the immune signaling the
patient with just a single number which
was nice we try this and we got quite
nice confirmation we were able to find
the immune signaling signal there at the
signal inside the can the signal of
melanocytes and were able to put eyes in
new samples with this score we also were
able to combine together the hazards in
coming from the Cox regression model in
order to be able to predict what is the
hazard for each particular patient so
just to summarize or publish the second
part we tested our implementation of
consensus ACA the IC is able to
decomposed about data set into
meaningful signals that we saw not only
with this data set but also visible the
data set data sets and the new samples
are properly mapped into the space to
from the parent component not like with
PCA but here you can really find them
back in this meaningful component for
example signals beyond of keratinocytes
and then you see how your samples are
behaving there and netted allow
classifying is and scouring new patients
which is interesting for clinical
research study
so to the final slide I would like to
thank all the people who work with me
and the first project in the second
project including our team here and the
pertinent Genome Research Unit at
Luxembourg into the house but also from
the neuron ecology unit of our
institution with which is led by
professors
Monique Lou and also our collaborators
from university especially dr. Stephanie
crys with whom we perform the study on
melanoma and special thanks to dr. Andre
xenovia from Institute quarry in France
in Paris who is a very strong promoter
of the method in Europe I think in all
the independent component analysis
method so thank you very much for your
attention now I think we have time for
questions
thank you dr. nazar all for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that answer question box located on
the far left of your screen well answer
as many questions as we have time for so
let's get started our first question is
if the length has an effect on RNA
sequencing results why didn't you use
expression measures that are corrected
for the length bias like fpkm
or TPM yes thank you very much it's a
very good question in fact so what we
observed us we tested this in fact we
tested this and what we observed that
using fpkm does not reduce the
stochastic CT you just remove their
lengths from consideration but you still
have stochastic noise so you do not have
many differentially expressed genes with
small lengths the first point is this
the second point is that in this
situation we cannot use any more models
with binomial noise wispy normal signal
whose negative binomial signal sorry
and we have to use Lima so we get even
smaller number of significant genes well
and finally we did not see that there
was any improvement in terms of German
gene ontology term bias that's it our
next question is can the bias be linked
to a specific enrichment will used did
you use background list of genes during
the enrichment yes thanks for the second
part of the question absolutely we
corrected we took into account in fact
to reference list of genes those which
are in general presented on the platform
and those which are actually expressed
in this tissue and got very similar
results in fact for the first part of
the question we tried three different
methods namely top geo and geo check
from our but also online tool enrich are
and in addition to this we confirm the
results with rectum but when Iser rectum
PA and we saw the similar bias there as
well our next question is when are you
planning to publish the results of your
second part independent component
analysis for patient classification well
we are finalizing the manuscript right
now and going it's going to be submitted
sale next month hopefully by the way for
there are some people who are interested
in the method they are welcome to
contact us and yeah we can communicate
by email about about the methods thank
you doctor Nazareth it looks like we
have time for one more question how is
your experience with the tax software is
it easy to you and it is and is it
sufficient for the analysis mm-hmm
yes in fact um I have some experience
the tax software appeared last year in
this current form and in fact we need to
stop one of our just preparation because
of it because we wanted to publish
something related to their analysis to
the pipelines
but unfortunately unfortunately for all
the rest this part was covered by the
new tool it is quite enough - for the
analysis for the standards analysis of a
few metrics or dramafever arrays let's
say like this if you need something more
advanced then maybe you will need to use
our afterwards but it's very good when
you need to load the data to normalize
the data to see what's up there with
experiments are there producible what
are the outliers and so on and I think
which I specifically like is that the
software allow for our maybes GC content
correction which is not so often
let's see thank you again dr. nazarov
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
the registration we'd also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand for September of 2018
labret will alert a via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with their colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye